c'est le premier conseil national avec
une toute nouvelle équipe
cette journée m'inspire vraiment le
début d'une nouvelle aventure pour les
républicains
on sent une envie de faire les choses
renouvellement nouveau départ j'avais de
chabeuil dans la drôme mais je me suis
déplacé pour le conseil national des
républicains je suis militant à clermont
ferrand et malaussanne luxe secrétaire
territorial de la guyane française vous
êtes là et ce jour marque le premier
jour de notre reconstruction
à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle droite qui commence laurent m'a
proposé de présider cette assemblée
nationale des militants et de notre
mouvement
j'accepte cette mission avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé parce qu'elle est
synonyme de diversité
le conseil national pour moi c'est le
moyen pour se rassembler pour que
finalement on retrouve une ligne
directrice le mouvement est bien vivant
et élus sont motivés les jeunes sont
très motivés être rassemblées être
porteur d'espoir pour la jeunesse de
france d'être unie derrière notre
nouvelle équipe et d'avancer vers les
projets de ces séances laurent tu trahis
devant nous un chemin une voix un espoir
j'ai confiance à laurent wauquiez j'ai
confiance à vous tous avec une droite de
retour tous derrière laurent wauquiez ça
me donne envie de m'engager encore plus
parce que laurent wauquiez est quelqu'un
de dynamique
je veux que nous puissions dire très
sereinement mais avec la plus grande
énergie
nous sommes de droite et nous sommes à
nouveau fier d'être de droite
[Applaudissements]
il ya de la vitalité il ya l'énergie et
surtout il ya du courage et de l'audace
le discours de laurent wauquiez présent
12 yast j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment
plein d'énergie plein d'élan j'ai voulu
donner sa chance à une nouvelle
génération
elle est pleine d'énergie elle est
pleine dent vie nous sommes le coeur
battant de notre famille politique
n'ayant pas peur de ce que nous sommes
et ensemble réussissons pour les
républicains
et pour la france on a du talent on a de
la compétence on line ligne
on a une voix on a des quadras des
trentenaires de grande qualité et en
plus on a les anciens qui ont vraiment
envie de retourner à la maison
donc c'est plein d'espoir pour la suite
on a une président de la région ile de
france qu'elle a également pour faire
entendre sa voir il y à une droite
qu'elle peut être diverse mais qu'il ya
une droite une seule famille politique
c'est en débattant que l'on peut porter
ses idées
on reste dans sa famille politique
on ne brade pas ses idées pour un poste
au gouvernement
et beaucoup de promesses tenues sur plus
d coûte de la base on n'a pas été déçu
de déjeuner avec le bureau il ya une
proximité qu'on n'avait pas avant
c'est quelqu'un qui est à l' écoute qui
veut que les idées émergent de la base
des déterminé il ya cette volonté et il
la transmet est vraiment j'y croyais
bien moi je vous invite à cette
politique des convictions je vous invite
à cette politique du courage je vous
invite à sonner le réveil de la france
vive la république et vive la france
là